okay so he's he's got his hair maker
okay he's way bigger than me so i'm not
gonna sit here
and try to stop this thing okay so
i have to use my jiu-jitsu so my hand
does go up
but you're going to feel that pressure
and you're going to move inside of
it okay and then you're going to find
the inside
that's your distance to get out of
weapon retention issue range okay so the
arm
the arm does make contact but then it
heals and comes around and drops the
elbow on the outside
so don't have no contact
but don't brace on this thing either
so boom
and you're moving inside so you need the
other honda
so uh you can't keep turning in on this
because you won't get the
projection angle all right so you have
to take a lace
foam and you can get it so
you only move in inside of that circle
okay
and then that's it
good so
inside
watch that you don't keep turning
you want to understand
why you're doing one thing and it's got
to be because i can't do something else
okay that's how you get a tactical sense
all right
so if if if he takes his final stance
out here
you see so that means this can't be uh
where this technique would be viable you
see if he takes his stance out here
i would do something like that right or
get my baton out
so it's gotta be more like interviews
it's more of an ambush situation
okay so if it's an ambush situation and
he goes to throw his strike that's why i
got to defend the strike i'm not going
to drop my weapons
but i don't have the time to do this big
deviation
because if i take space i require time
and time's not practical here
so my deviation is inside
inside just get get your head get your
head
off you get it that's all you're doing
so you know another strategy you could
do you're in here but
he's bigger than me so i don't want to
grapple him okay
so if i
that's that's the technique so try not
to move your feet so much okay
start close